[Musique]
quand une nouvelle page se tourne
je ressens des frissons tout le long de
ma colonne vertébrale il n'y a rien de
plus beau costume
c'est ça la décence
une découverte constante
sera pas content que nos choix peuvent
tout changer
peut-être qu ensemble
parce que tant qu'il y aura quelque
chose à découvrir alors tous nous
semblera encore possible
[Musique]
il ya un fort
pensez-vous l'attraper au petit déjeuner
des aides mort aventis j'ai une idée
seulement ça va prendre clair vous
expliquer pourquoi est ce qui vous pose
gamine
je m'appelle et me dé la santé vais vous
raconter la fin du monde comme besoin de
fric
j'ai une grosse facture d'électricité et
si je te confie le récit du mois et on
sent capable s'appelle ciment la mère
est morte il ya six mois et juste au
moment où c'est arrivé c'est exactement
vous êtes là il a vu madonna vu quoi le
fantôme de sa mère
sur celle ci
disparu
je sais pas
je connais quelqu'un qui la ramène chez
déterminé semaines pour s'achever
qu'est ce qui t'a fait mr je le vois tu
vois quoi mon père
tu t'es fait avoir elle a que j'aurai
beaucoup d'imagination disent quelque
chose d'héroïque ctl avec beast ont pu
en cuir rouge et moi ce que tu vas voir
étages comprend pas la souris 1 ce qui
reste des tendresses de merde de
mensonges qui les gardent ce que je veux
pas c'est partager partager avec qui
avec quoi tu parles du noir [ __ ] elle
est morte mais tulle m comme t'as jamais
aimé personne ce que je peux faire moi
[Musique]
même quoi
même si intérêt du jeu
je prends une grosse malle au chocolat
trempés dans le chocolat tout pour
convaincre les gens passaient bien me
replacer bien avant les faits déjà finir
et moi je peux me tenais à s'attarder en
plus soit tardif il contraint d'accorder
pense qu'il ya un truc tu ressembles se
trouve pas qui est vraiment et salut fis
totalement dans la sotoco trop de tours
wall est vraiment accro ici contre 1
paul je vous restez trop en classe dans
cette école ne te demander quand est
vraiment brillante toi on va peut-être
après on a aimé les gens qui vous aiment
et arrêter de courir la pression qui
nous avons un homme droit
whatever gets pour rapport ici personne
me dit l'immersion koné d'intego stick
personnes que les phillies
on la connaît c'est le mot car pour la
chanteuse
l'écrivain
[Musique]
la fin
où est jeune et active
sauf moi
[Musique]
presse
mmx
[Musique]
inutile
comme ce tueur
de qui a pu voir six mois d'essai
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le journal el moudjahid
deiss
mais
c'est faux
[Musique]
il
au triple
le tout
à la plage
[Musique]
wilma
en
[Musique]
je sais ce qu'elle risque
on a manqué près
[Musique]
c'est au prince
ce n'est fait
une onde de choc entre équipes au
cameroun
le permettait
les gens ont dit tellement de choses
méchantes sur toi pendant toutes ces
années mais ça
je peux pas l'ignorer j'ai tellement
tellement
vos relations se sont dégradées dans
votre séjour en prison
il n'est pas trop tard pour construire
des ponts
tu es venu pour dire quelque chose ok je
pensais que j'aurais accompli tellement
plus de choses à mon âge j'ai 36 ans
tout ça
si on fait
[Applaudissements]
on est de retour
qu'est ce qui t'arrive emec peut-être
[ __ ] de légende
d'où on vient la vie c'est un risque
le sommet
[Musique]
ça vaut le coup peur de ce qu'on aime sa
famille attention à toi
je suis vraiment désolé pour arriver au
top pour ce que tu veux tu dois battre
m
et
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tout va bien ça va
s'améliorer
[Applaudissements]